hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about the big questions that dark season
2 left unanswered and what we can expect
to get answers for in season 3 dark can
be confusing what with characters moving
through time and each season seems to
ask more questions than it answers in
this video I'll discuss the biggest
questions I want answers to after season
2 of dark and you can let me know what
yours are in the comments real quick
there's been a lot of spoilery images
from season 3 filming filtering out I
decided to leave those out of this video
I'm gonna make a second video to discuss
those rather than including them here
some people don't like to see stuff like
that in advance so this seems like the
best solution this video will contain
spoilers for everything through season
two though so now that you've been
warned let's get into it first question
I have is who is the new Martha and how
does she change things the big cherry on
top twists of season 2 was the arrival
of an alternate Martha in windin who
saves younger Jonas from the apocalypse
right after he watches his Martha the
Martha and his world die when Jonas
asked this new character what time did
you come from she answers the question
isn't what time the question is what
world obviously this feels related to
Claudia mentioning that she's seen a
world without Jonas and yeah it looks
like there is at least one more windin
or one more world that we have to
explore just when you think you got a
handle on the rules of time travel
inside dark story and wrap your head
around the deterministic structure where
everything that's happened has always
happened and there's no free will
here comes Martin number 2 when we know
Martin number 1 has definitely just died
it's a turn that brings up a lot of
questions
is this the loophole that Adam has
talked about are they going to her world
right now has this always happened the
good news is more Marta albeit not the
same Marta but bad news is that her
existence definitely complicates things
I'm going to avoid going down rabbit
holes here because there are a lot of
other questions to get into and I think
they've given us exactly as much as they
want us to know at this point but let me
know what you think in the comment
about who alt Martha is and how she
changes things one of the big debates is
whether this has always happened or if
this is the first time and it's happened
I tend to think it always has but let me
know how you're sorting it out the next
question is where did Katerina go at the
end of season 2 we see Katerina
opened the door in the caves after being
led there by some mysterious particles
or whatever you wish to call them
she looked poised to move through the
passage so when will she end up her son
Mikkel found himself stuck in 1986 after
passing through the caves and her
husband Ulrich landed in 1953 Katerina
was studying the maps and essentially
doing all the same things Jonas was
doing before he finally was successful
in moving through the passage but if
that has any bearing on what time period
shall come out in on the other side it's
impossible to tell expect that she would
be trying to get to her son Mikal first
and foremost but it also seems unlikely
that she has any control over where and
when she goes when she passes through
either way she should be somewhere other
than 2020 where the apocalypse just went
down and I'm looking forward to see what
she gets into the next question is is
Adam actually Jonas and if so how did he
become Adam I'm pretty firmly in the
Adam is Jonas camp and I don't spend
very much time wondering if he might be
someone else but there's a lot of other
people who think he could actually be
Bartos one of the reasons I tend to
think that he is who he says he is is
because it works pretty well that way to
me it makes sense that the one pulling
the strings would be the character we've
been watching from the beginning rather
than there being some big hidden twists
involved another reason I feel pretty
comfortable with the story as it is is
because the official guide web site that
they put together says that he's Jonas
and I don't think that that is an
elaborate hoax I could be wrong but it
feels pretty honest from my point of
view what's more interesting to me is
how over the 33 years stranger Jonas
turns into Adam we know that the
stranger was moved to save Magnus
Franziska and bartosh after he read the
letter
that young Noah gave him we've seen his
lair under the church that exists in
1921 and we've seen the photo of sick
mundus that was taken in that same year
will season three fill in those blanks
for us that leads directly into the next
question which is when did Jonas Magnus
Franziska and bartosh go
since these characters are traveling
with the time house device we can assume
that they're going to be jumping around
some I suppose that where they go
initially to survive the apocalypse
isn't that important my question is will
they settle in 1888 and live there until
we meet at least some of them again in
1921 that seems the most likely to me
but there could be many steps that
unfold before they actually get there or
they could never go there at all
let me know what you think and I
mentioned the letter that's another big
question in my mind - what does the
letter say that young Noah delivered to
Jonas he said it came from Marta that
doesn't really make sense unless of
course it's the alt Martha who wrote it
it seems way more likely that Adam would
have written it but either way is this
the point where he learned something
beyond what we see him do as in this one
he starts to really change to become
Adam it's hard to say all I know is that
there's a lot of letters flying around
in this world and I feel suspicious
about every one of them like who wrote
them why they wrote them all the way out
the next question is what role will
Hannah play in the past we know that
Hannah ended up in 1954 at the end of
season two and she seems to be
indicating that she might stay there
there's also a hint that there may be
some chemistry going on between her and
the young or Egon and we also know that
Katarina is moving through time and it
would be interesting if those two cross
paths again I think it's safe to say
that Hannah will stay in 1954 for a
while and I can't see her not getting
mixed up with the other characters in
that time there are some theories about
how things turn out based on some of
those behind the scenes photos that the
showrunners been posting that I
mentioned in the beginning like I said I
won't get into those here but check out
the season 3 spoilers video that
make after this one for more on that in
the meantime let me know how you think
her presence in the 50s will change
things next question is there more to
Alexander's story than we know
Alexander T demons history as Boris nee
Wald is mysterious the circumstances
around his arrival and Wendon make it
seem to me that there's definitely more
going on with this character but at the
same time he's done a lot of other stuff
as well so is it just coincidence that
he shows up bleeding running from the
law
next to the caves back in 1986 when he
shows up we know that that something
went down in Marburg he's worried about
being found out about that but then we
also have Claussen come into the story
to me it appears that Boris nee Wald and
Alexander Kohler Klaus ins brother were
the two that were on the run so what
does that actually mean for the real
Alexander Kohler did he go somewhere and
on top of that we don't know where
Alexander Tiedemann came from in the
story where everyone is essentially
connected so I hope we find out more
about his backstory we'll have to wait
and see speaking about not knowing where
people come from the next big question I
have is who are knowin Agnes's parents I
did a detailed family tree about a week
ago if you haven't seen that video you
should check it out but when I look at
that
the biggest mystery to me is where Noah
and Agnes came from in the first place
we saw them living with Erna in the 1921
timeline but beyond that we can't really
trust anything they say as far as Agnes
telling the T demons when she first
moves in she says her grandmother was
from Linden and I think that is probably
true but we don't know anything else
about who her actual parents are and
when you look at the family tree it has
pretty big impact on how everybody's
connected she is the first Nielson that
we know of and it just builds from there
speaking of Noah how did Noah Elizabeth
and baby Charlotte get split up this
whole thing's pretty interesting of
course you know Elizabeth and Charlotte
are each other's mothers we know that
these two are standing getting ready to
touch through the wormhole at the end of
season two
another question in itself where did
they end up but I'm curious because
we've seen photos what happens after the
bunker did they stay in the regular time
line do they move into the future and
have the child there do they go back
somewhere and have the child and then
ultimately how do they get separated
how does young Charlotte end up in the
care of HG tan house that could be very
well connected to the next question
which is what's Claudia really trying to
do we have a pretty good idea that Adam
is true when he says that he's at war
with time course he lies about
everything to get people to do different
things but I feel like he's probably
trying to do something like that he's
trying to break the cycle
Claudia is more mysterious to me because
several characters align themselves with
her and then pull back and change sides
and we see that the biggest things that
happened to claudia as far as personal
loss is the death of her father and we
know that regina is dying and that she
feels remorse about not spending more
time with her but what is she actually
trying to accomplish is she trying to do
something that we haven't quite
understood yet because she does bring up
the fact that she's seen the world
without Jonas and then we eventually see
her come to the end of her life I tend
to think that she exists based on what
we've seen into the future like she's
definitely left that string wall behind
in the bunker that Jonas comes across in
2053 everything about what Elizabeth's
doing when we run into her in the future
seems to be influenced by Claudia those
two would have been there together
building the future if you will so I
think it's a pretty big mystery about
what Claudia is actually trying to
accomplish in relation to being at odds
with Adam another thing I think about
when I think about the people who
survived I mean Regina has terminal
cancer so I'm expecting that she may die
because of that I don't think that
health care is going to be improved in
the near future so she's got that to
deal with the next question then is what
happens to Peter after that Charlotte's
not there with him she touches hands
with Elizabeth we don't know where
she'll end up but Peter will exist and
he's a mystery already we don't know who
is
parents really are we don't know where
he came from why he showed up in 87
instead of being born in windin where
everybody knew about it so there's
definitely some hints that he might play
a really large role as being one of the
survivors that kind of segues into the
next question and that is who are all
the new actors gonna play an article on
The Hollywood Reporter website listed
several new actors that were added to
the cast for season three we see them
all here we got a Barbara Hans deal
Jacob deal Nina a Sammy and an axel out
of these Sammy has been credited as
playing a small role in season 1 episode
6 I believe he was this actor from
Martha's play but he's also being listed
as a new character which means that he's
probably not still playing this exact
same guy this actor has been in some of
those behind the scenes photos that I've
been talking about so you can learn more
about those when I make the next video
Hans and Jacob are father and son in
real life for a show that does a good
job of casting actors that look alike
and they look like aged up versions of
each other hiring the actual father and
son is pretty interesting it seems more
likely that they would play the same
character at different ages rather than
a father and son because the only
younger character who doesn't already
have confirmed older versions is bartosh
and I don't really see a resemblance
there the German web site movie pilot
made an interesting connection though
Sami Jacob and Hans do kind of share a
resemblance does that mean that we could
be getting a new character that we're
gonna see at all three different ages at
this point in the story two of the other
new actors are in the 70s and this is
how it connects to Peter I thought of
him right away since we know he survives
in the bunker an axel Werner could be
the older Peter Barbara is hard to pin
down because Claudia Jenna and Ennis are
the only female characters we've seen in
that age group she could be playing an
older Charlotte Elizabeth or Agnes but
then there's a lot of other
possibilities as well if you look at the
family tree Nina on the other hand is in
her 50s which lines her up pretty good
to be an older version of Marta but then
have to ask the question again are we
going to see that much of the
alternative world that we see older
versions of these people as well these
last questions I'm just gonna throw them
out there and not go into him as deeply
who is Celia if she first showed up at
the end of season one and it feels like
she has to be connected to someone in
the four main family somehow next who
wrote the leather-bound notebook Adam
seems like a good candidate but he seems
rather interested in getting the missing
pages back from Claudia at the same time
all we know for sure is that it's said
to be written by someone who had already
seen in the past in the future so who is
the author was this character actually
an older bartosh I tend to think it was
but if that's the case why haven't they
named him that yet have we already seen
evidence of multiple worlds the
different calendars in the Conrad house
is the best evidence for that but
there's other things that pop out to
fans as well some of them are bound to
be production errors but it seems weird
that they would all be production errors
and of course the last question is what
happened to Torben Bowlers I there are
so many more questions I actually have
but I had to try to keep this as short
as it makes sense to do in this format
so I'm gonna end it there let me know
what questions you have let me know what
you think about my questions how did you
feel about the whole Marta from another
world twist when it happened if I'm
honest at first I really didn't enjoy it
I didn't like say oh the whole thing's
ruined and get pissed or anything but it
wasn't what I was expecting and it took
a little while to set in of course
knowing that there's only three seasons
planned and that they have an end point
in mind really helps in that regard
but what do you think tell me in the
comments tell me what you want to see as
far as new videos about dark we out
about a year until we're gonna see any
more episodes so I'm interested to hear
what you think please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon